Вітаю вас.
Мене звуть Юрій. Я викладач математики
креативної міжнародної дитячої школи.
Сьогодні у нас урок математики в 6 класі.
Розв’язування рівнянь за
допомогою їх властивостей.
Отже, давайте згадаємо деякі нюанси.
Нагадаю, що основна
властивість рівнянь звучить так:
до обох частин рівняння можна
додати або відняти одне й те саме число,
при цьому корені рівняння не зміняться.
Наслідок з цієї властивості такий:
з довільної частини рівняння
можна переносити доданок,
при цьому
потрібно змінити його знак на протилежний.
Друга властивість нам каже, що
обидві частини рівняння можна
множити або ділити на число, яке,
увага, відмінне від нуля.
Отже, давайте застосуємо дані
властивості для розв’язування рівнянь.
9х -26=
30-5х
Подивіться, будь ласка, уважно.
В даному випадку
доданки з невідомими у вас
знаходяться і в лівій, і в правій частині.
Для того, щоб розв’язати рівняння
такого виду, ваша задача така.
Ви повинні всі доданки з
невідомими перенести в ліву частину,
а всі відомі доданки
перенести в праву частину.
Отже,
-5х, ми маємо перенести в ліву частину.
Відповідно
-26 ми повинні перенести в праву частину.
Тобто перенести через знак «дорівнює».
Нагадаю, що коли ми
переносимо доданок в іншу частину,
знак цього доданку
змінюється на протилежний.
В лівій частині 9х так і залишається.
-5х переходить в ліву частину як +5х.
Дорівнює.
В правій частині 30 так і залишається.
-26 переходить в праву
частину зі знаком +26.
Зводимо подібні доданки.
9х+5х = 14х
30+26=56.
Надалі, щоб знайти корінь
або розв’язати це рівняння,
потрібно просто 56 розділити на 14.
Відповідь легко знаходиться, х=4.
Запис розв’язування ви бачите на дошці.
Для розв’язування наступного прикладу
нам треба згадати деякі
нюанси з властивостей множення.
Увага на екран!
Завдання і варіанти відповідей
на нього ви бачите на екрані.
Отже, правильна відповідь В.
Поясню чому.
Якщо у вас перед дужками стоїть знак «-»,
ви повинні цей мінус і дужки прибрати,
а всі доданки, які знаходяться
в дужках, змінити на протилежні.
Перепишу.
Було 8n, стане мінус 8n.
Було -5, стане +5.
Зводимо подібні доданки.
3n мінус 8n, буде мінус 5n.
+5 переписуємо.
Правильна відповідь В.
Розв’яжемо наступний приклад.
5(х-4)= х+8.
Ми зараз не можемо
переносити доданки з обох частин.
Спочатку ми повинні
розкрити дужки в лівій частині.
Для цього застосуємо
розподільну властивість множення.
5 множиться на (х-4),
це буде означати, що
вираз набуває такого вигляду:
5 множиться на х – це буде
5x, -5 множиться на 4, -20.
Дорівнює х+8.
А ось тепер ми переносимо
доданки з невідомими ліворуч,
а доданки з відомими переносимо праворуч.
В правій частині в мене є х, він
невідомий, я буду його переносити ліворуч.
В лівій частині у мене відоме -20,
я буду переносити його праворуч.
Записую що в мене вийде.
Увага!
Якщо перед якимось
доданком не стоїть ніякого знаку,
це означає, що перед ним стоїть знак «+».
Просто х або +x при переносі в
ліву частину буде виглядати як -х.
Дорівнює.
-20 переноситься в праву частину.
В правій же частині в
мене вже є +8 або просто 8
і, відповідно, додати 20.
5х-х буде дорівнювати 4х.
У більшості виникає
проблеми з цим прикладом.
Але розкажу вам таке.
Якщо біля якогось невідомого не
стоїть ніякого коефіцієнту, тобто числа,
ви можете просто приписати 1.
Тобто x – це те саме, що 1х.
Відповідно 5х-1х=4х
8+20=28; 4 х=28.
Дуже легко знаходить х.
Я одразу запишу, що х =28:4, це буде 7.
Відповідь х=7.
Розв’яжемо наступне рівняння.
7х+9
відняти 11х -7.
Обидва ці вирази у нас в дужках.
Дорівнює 8.
Для розв’язання цього прикладу
потрібно для початку розкрити дужки.
Перші дужки можна просто прибрати,
адже перед ними не стоїть ніякого знаку.
Тобто уявний «+».
7х+9.
Перед другими дужками стоїть знак «-»,
тобто мінус і дужки прибираються,
а кожен доданок з дужок,
змінює свій знак на протилежний.
-11х+7=8.
Зараз я в лівій частині
зведу подібні доданки.
Підкреслюю їх однаковими рисками.
7х зводиться з -11х.
+9 зводиться з +7.
7х мінус 11х, буде -4х.
+9 додати +7, буде +16.
-4х+16=8.
Тепер +16 я перенесу в праву частину.
Відповідно в правій частині
воно в мене буде виглядати як -16.
-4х=8-16.
Обчислюю значення правої частини.
-4х=-8.
Тепер для того щоб знайти х,
мені потрібно -8 розділити на -4.
Коли два знаки стоять поруч,
знак «ділення» і знак «мінус», я
повинен знак «мінус» взяти у дужки.
Не забувайте про це.
Х = -8: (-4);
х = 2
Це і є наша відповідь.
Запис рівняння ви бачите на дошці.
Розв’яжемо наступний приклад.
Три четвертих
помножити на дужку, в якій одна шоста х
мінус одна третя,
Дорівнює:
2x відняти одинадцять цілих одна друга
(запис дивимось на дошці).
Для початку я повинен в
лівій частині розкрити дужки.
Використовую розподільну
властивість множення.
Відповідно
три четвертих множиться на одну шосту х,
відняти три четвертих
множиться на одну третю.
Праву частину в даному
випадку я просто переписую.
Дивимось запис на екрані.
Три четвертих помножити на одну шосту.
Можна скоротити це множення.
В даному випадку 3 і 6
скорочується, тут буде 1, тут 2.
Одна четверта помножити на
одну другу, буде одна восьма х.
Три четвертих помножити на одну третю,
знову ж таки, трійки
скочуються, будуть одинички.
Одна четверта помножити на одну
першу, буде просто одна четверта.
Надалі використовую властивість рівняння:
те, що я можу переносити
доданки з однієї частини в іншу.
Переношу 2 х в ліву частину,
оскільки це доданок з невідомим іксом,
а мінус одну четверту
переношу в праву частину.
Записую що в мене вийде.
Одна восьма x відняти 2 x
дорівнює
мінус 11 цілих одна друга, бо воно в
мене в правій частині так і залишилось.
І мінус одна четверта перейде в
праву частинку як плюс одна четверта.
Запис рівняння ви бачите на екрані.
Зводимо подібні доданки в лівій частині.
Для того, щоб звести подібні доданки,
нам потрібно їх звести
до спільного знаменника.
Двійку я запишу як дві перших.
Отже,
спільний знаменник у чисел 8 і 1 буде 8.
до першого числа додатковий
множник 1, а для другого відповідно 8.
В правій частині спільний
знаменник чисел 2 і 4, буде 4.
Відповідно додатковий множник
до другого числа 1, до першого 2.
Пророблюю зведення відповідних доданків.
Одна восьма х мінус
шістнадцять восьмих х дорівнює
мінус 11 цілих дві четвертих
плюс одна четверта.
Одна восьма х мінус шістнадцять восьмих х
буде дорівнювати мінус
п’ятнадцять восьмих x.
Мінус 11 цілих дві
четвертих плюс одна четверта
буде дорівнювати мінус
11 цілих одна четверта.
Запис дивимось на дошці.
Тепер для того, щоб знайти х,
я перейду на ліву частин,
мені потрібно мінус 11 цілих одну четверту
розділити на мінус п’ятнадцять восьмих.
Запишу це зліва (запис дивимось на дошці)
x дорівнює мінус 11 цілих одна четверта
розділити на мінус п’ятнадцять восьмих.
Для того, щоб проробити зараз
ділення, я повинен перевести
це мішане число – мінус
11 цілих одна четверта
в неправильний дріб.
Зроблю це.
Нагадаю, потрібно 11 помножити на 4
і додати до чисельника, тобто одиничку.
А знаменник залишити без змін.
X дорівнює:
мінус в мене залишається,
тобто буде мінус (11 на 4 =44, плюс 1), 45
і знаменник четвертих залишається.
Сорок п’ять четвертих треба поділити
на мінус п’ятнадцять восьмих, тобто
помножити на обернений дріб.
Обернений дріб мається на увазі, що
чисельник і знаменник змінюються місцями.
Фінальний знак цього добутку буде такий:
мінус помножити на мінус, буде плюс.
Отже, х буде дорівнювати:
в попередній дії я пророблю скорочення.
4 і 8 скорочуються на 4 – це буде 1.
8 і 4 – це буде 2.
45 і 15 скорочуються на 15.
Відповідно 45 на 15, це буде 3.
15 на 15, буде 1.
Далі пророблюємо множення.
3 помножити на 2, буде 6.
1 помножити на 1, буде 1.
Тобто шість перших або просто 6. х =6.
Увага, знак у нас «+».
Тому що мінус число ми
множимо на плюс число.
Приклад вирішено.
Розв’яжемо деякі нестандартні приклади.
3(х+6)=х+2(х+9).
Нагадаю,
для того, щоб розв’язати таке рівняння,
його спочатку необхідно спростити.
Тобто розкрити дужки в лівій
частині і, увага, в правій частині
я теж повинен розкрити дужки.
Далі, якщо це можливо, в кожній
частині звести подібні доданки.
Вже після цього невідомі
доданки переносити ліворуч,
а відомі доданки переносити праворуч.
Давайте проробимо всі ці дії.
Три множиться на х+6. Використовую
розподільну властивість множення.
Тобто буде 3х і 3
помножити на 6, буде 18.
Додати х.
Зараз 2 множиться на (х+9).
Тобто буде плюс 2х, плюс (увага!) 18.
3х+18=х+2х+18.
В правій частині зараз
можна легко побачити, що
x додати 2, ми можемо
звести це як подібні доданки.
Це буде скільки?
3х.
Запис рівняння ви бачите на дошці.
Далі всі невідомі доданки я переношу
ліворуч, а всі відомі доданки – праворуч.
Відповідно
мені потрібно 3х перенести ліворуч,
а +18 перенести праворуч.
Що в мене вийде.
В лівій частині 3х вже було,
в правій частині воно теж
було 3х зі знаком плюс,
тому в лівій частині воно стане мінус 3х.
Дорівнює.
В правій частині у мене було 18.
З лівої частини +18 перейде як мінус 18.
Подивіться, будь ласка, уважно.
Що у вас виходить?
3х відняти 3х буде 0.
Дорівнює.
Кажуть, що доданки взаємознищуються.
Увага, не скорочуються,
а взаємознищуються.
18 мінус 18 дорівнює теж нулю.
Тобто що ми маємо?
Після всіх перетворень рівняння
у нас вийшла правильна рівність.
Скажіть, будь ласка, нуль
дорівнює нулю – це ж правда?
Так, правда.
Отже, якщо після всіх перетворень,
у вас вийшла правильна рівність,
ви з повною впевненістю можете сказати,
що рівняння має безліч розв’язків.
Тобто яке б х ви не
підставили в своє рівняння,
відповідь завжди буде правильна.
Рівняння
має
безліч
розв’язків.
Або ще пишуть
цю фразу як:
х належить R.
Х належить множині усіх дійсних чисел.
Розв’яжемо схожий приклад,
але з деяким іншим сценарієм.
2(8х-7)= 18-4(5-4х).
Приклад ніби трошки складніший,
але все одно ми справимось.
Спочатку ми повинні і в лівій, і
в правій частині розкрити дужки.
2 множиться на (8х-7),
тобто 2 помножити на 8х буде 16х.
Увага!
Мінус, 2 множиться на мінус 7, буде 14.
Дорівнює: 18 я в даному
випадку просто переписую.
А тепер увага!
Момент, в якому роблять
більшість учнів помилки.
У вас мінус 4 множиться
на дужку, в якій (5-4х).
Чомусь забувають про цей мінус і
застосовують його лише до першого доданку.
Мінус 4 помножити на 5, буде мінус 20.
Досить часто пишуть знак мінус.
Але ж придивіться, будь ласка,
ви мінус 4 множите на мінус 4х.
Тому результатом у вас буде плюс 16х.
Запис рівняння ви бачите на екрані.
Переношу всі невідомі доданки
ліворуч, всі відомі доданки праворуч.
З лівої частини 16х так і залишається,
з правої частини +16х я переношу ліворуч.
Відповідно відомі доданки
мінус 14 я переношу праворуч,
не забуваю змінювати його знак.
Результат: 16х так і залишається,
плюс 16х буде мінус 16х.
Воно переноситься з іншим знаком.
З правої частини 18
мінус 20 так і залишається.
Ми, до речі, могли його
порахувати – скільки це буде.
І, відповідно, мінус 14 переноситься
сюди зі знаком плюс, буде +14.
В лівій частині ви можете бачити, що
16х-16х взаємознищуються, це буде нуль.
До речі, показувати це можна закресленням.
Нуль дорівнює:
18 мінус 20, буде мінус 2,
додати 14, дорівнює 12. 0=12.
Увага, в попередньому прикладі у
нас в кінці виходила правильна рівність.
В даному прикладі у нас
виходить неправильна рівність.
Бо нуль не дорівнює 12.
Тому відповідь на цей приклад така.
Немає коренів, які б
задовольняли дане рівняння.
Тобто рівняння не має розв’язків.
Так і пишуть:
дивимось на дошку
або ж пишуть таким чином:
порожня множина.
Знак порожньої множини ви бачите на екрані
На цьому наш урок закінчено.
Ми з вами опрацювали рівняння,
які розв’язуються за
допомогою їх властивостей.
Домашнє завдання у вас на екрані.
До наступних зустрічей!